wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
alisa mir geht es super und dir danke
emma und wer bist du ich bin niko alm
nico du kannst dich aus deutschland oder
entschuldigung
woher kommst du ich bin max und ich
komme aus deutschland
ich kann mir auch aus deutschland ich
bin nie co ich komme aus dem spain
spanien spanien ja ich komme aus spanien
und woher kommst du genau woher wo
wohnst du entspannend ist in barcelona
oder madrid sevilla
du wohnst in zivil ich wohne ins team
ico war auch am flughafen hat ein
problem seine tasche ist weg und was
machst du jetzt
ich suche meine tante und konstante
wohnt hier in deutschland aber er hat
die adressen musst kannst du deine tante
anrufen
meine tasche ist weg mein telefon ist
weg und die nummer ist und deine familie
kannst du deine familie anrufen kann
dein vater licht helfen erst vor der
polizei
gute idee mein vater ist polizist police
vielleicht hätte uns moment
[Musik]